It's This American Life from WBEZ Chicago. I'm Ira Glass.
这是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。
So there's a whole infrastructure that springs into action when a mass shooting happens. There's the police and SWAT teams, of course, and the Red Cross, the Billy Graham prayer truck, therapy dogs. And there's this couple who shows up, this couple whose daughter died in a mass shooting. And they come, and what they do seems to be very effective.
当大规模枪击事件发生时，会有一整套基础设施立即投入运作。当然有警察和特警队，还有红十字会、葛培理祈祷车、治疗犬。然后会有一对夫妇出现，他们的女儿死于大规模枪击事件。他们来了，而且他们的所作所为似乎非常有效。
I don't need to tell you that our government has utterly failed at any kind of response to stop school shootings and mass shootings. In the wake of that, that nothingness, that non-response, parents of children who've died have stepped in in various ways.
我不用多说你也知道，我们的政府在阻止校园枪击和大规模枪击事件方面的反应彻底失败了。在那之后，在那样的虚无和不作为中，那些失去孩子的父母开始以各种方式介入。
Today, on our show, we have two stories for you about parents like these. In the second half hour of our show, we have a dad from Sandy Hook, who jumped into action after his son was killed, just took extraordinary measures, and got results.
今天，在我们的节目中，我们有关于这些父母的两个故事。在节目的下半小时，我们将讲述一位桑迪胡克小学的父亲，他在儿子遇害后采取了行动，采取了非凡的措施，并取得了成果。
But we're going to begin with this story about that couple, Sandy and Lonnie Phillips. They're out in Uvalde, Texas this week. They headed there straight from Buffalo, where, of course, 10 people were killed earlier this month in a grocery store. Their daughter, Jessi, died back in 2012 when a gunman opened fire in a movie theater in Aurora, Colorado. And since then, they've organized their lives to be able to reach out to other parents like themselves.
但我们先从关于桑迪·菲利普斯和朗尼·菲利普斯夫妇的故事开始。他们这周在德克萨斯州的乌瓦尔德。他们是从布法罗直接赶到那里的，本月早些时候，那里的一家杂货店有10人遇难。他们的女儿杰西在2012年科罗拉多州奥罗拉市的一家电影院发生的枪击案中丧生。从那时起，他们就重新安排了自己的生活，以便能够向其他像他们一样的父母伸出援手。
We did this story back in 2018, right after a school shooting in Santa Fe, Texas. But really, nothing has changed since we first heard this. I was re-listening to this story this week, and one thing that really hit me is how deeply it takes you into the place that-- I don't know, speaking for myself, I find myself thinking about all the time right now, which is what the parents and families in Uvalde, Texas are going through.
我们早在2018年就报道过这个故事，就在德克萨斯州圣达菲发生校园枪击案之后。但实际上，自我们第一次听到这个故事以来，什么都没有改变。我这周重听了这个故事，有一点真正触动我的是，它把你带入了那个——我不知道，就我个人而言，我现在发现自己一直在想那个地方，那就是德克萨斯州乌瓦尔德的父母和家庭正在经历的一切。
One of our producers, Miki Meek, put this together and spent time with Phillipses.
我们的制片人之一米奇·米克制作了这个节目，并和菲利普斯夫妇待在一起。
Sandy and Lonnie Phillips have traveled to eight mass shootings since Aurora. It started with Sandy Hook, then Isla Vista, San Bernardino, Orlando, Las Vegas, Sutherland Springs, Parkland, and then Santa Fe, Texas, which is where I met up with them in May, right after a student walked into the high school and killed 10 people. They pulled up in front of the school in their truck. Even though they've done this a lot, Sandy told me the discomfort and awkwardness they feel about showing up like this in a community has never gone away.
自奥罗拉枪击案以来，桑迪和朗尼·菲利普斯已经去了八个发生大规模枪击事件的地方。从桑迪胡克开始，接着是伊斯拉维斯塔、圣贝纳迪诺、奥兰多、拉斯维加斯、萨瑟兰泉、帕克兰，然后是德克萨斯州的圣达菲，五月份我就是在那里见到他们的，当时一名学生走进高中杀害了10个人。他们开着卡车停在学校前面。尽管他们已经做过很多次这样的事，但桑迪告诉我，他们在这样一个社区里露面时感受到的不适和尴尬从未消失过。
Are you ready for this?
准备好了吗？
But in Santa Fe, they just launched themselves in anyway. They're each wearing a big button with a photo of their daughter, Jessi, smiling. A memorial had just gone up on a big grassy lawn out front. There were 10 wood crosses, each with a red heart and a photo of the student or teacher who'd been killed. People were starting to leave teddy bears, flowers, and balloons.
但在圣达菲，他们还是直接进去了。他们每个人都戴着一枚大徽章，上面有他们女儿杰西微笑的照片。学校前的一大片草坪上刚刚竖起了一个纪念碑。那里有10个木十字架，每个十字架上都贴着一颗红心和遇难学生或老师的照片。人们开始放下泰迪熊、鲜花和气球。
What the Phillips do here is just talk to whoever wants to talk. They figure that'll lead them to families they might be useful to. And within seconds of getting out of their truck, they bump into a dazed teenage girl, wearing shorts and a Santa Fe High School soccer T-shirt.
菲利普斯夫妇在这里所做的就是和任何想交谈的人交谈。他们认为这会把他们带到可能需要帮助的家庭。下车几秒钟后，他们就遇到了一个神情恍惚的十几岁女孩，她穿着短裤和圣达菲高中足球队的T恤。
Excuse me, how are you doing?
不好意思，你还好吗？
I'm not OK.
我不好。
And here, the sound gets muffled because Sandy's tiny mic gets crushed when they hug. It's the main sound I remember from that day.
这里的声音变得模糊了，因为当他们拥抱时，桑迪的小麦克风被压到了。那是我那天记忆中最主要的声音。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
We're just so sorry this has happened to you, and your friends, and your families, and your community.
对于发生在你、你的朋友、你的家人和你们社区身上的事，我们感到非常抱歉。
Thank you so much.
非常感谢。
Another girl, a junior with light brown hair pulled back into a ponytail, walks up to them and stares at their buttons
另一个女孩，一个梳着马尾辫的浅棕色头发的大三学生，向他们走来，盯着他们的徽章。
We lost our daughter in a mass shooting six years ago.
我们在六年前的大规模枪击事件中失去了女儿。
Is that her?
那是她吗？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
She's pretty.
她很漂亮。
Thank you. She is. Inside and out, she was lovely, just like your friends.
谢谢。她是。由内而外，她都很可爱，就像你的朋友们一样。
Sandy is good at making people feel comfortable. She has a round, warm face, framed by a gray bob. She's maternal and keeps her comments caring and brief.
桑迪很擅长让人们感到舒服。她有一张圆圆的、温暖的脸，留着灰色的波波头。她很有母性，评论总是充满关怀且简短。
Lonnie stands right next to Sandy with his arm around her. Sandy's the one who mostly talks to the kids, but he's always by her side, listening intently. His presence helps her do this. He looks out for her, sometimes running ahead to start the AC in their truck before she climbs in.
朗尼紧挨着桑迪，手臂搂着她。主要是桑迪在和孩子们交谈，但他总是守在她身边，专注地倾听。他的存在帮助她完成了这些工作。他照顾她，有时会先跑过去发动卡车的空调，然后再让她爬进去。
Hi.
嗨。
My name's Tracy.
我叫特蕾西。
Hi, Tracy.
嗨，特蕾西。
I was surprised at how quickly people opened up to the Phillipses.
我很惊讶人们如此快地向菲利普斯夫妇敞开心扉。
Jessi.
杰西。
Jessi. Beautiful--
杰西。美丽的——
The girl who said "Jessi" was pretty. She started telling them that she escaped the shooting by hiding behind a building with other students. Now she just wanted to stay at home.
那个说“杰西”很漂亮的女孩。她开始告诉他们，她躲在建筑物后面和其他学生一起逃过了枪击。现在她只想待在家里。
But at home, all she could think about was the shooting. Scenes from that day kept re-playing through her head. Sandy doesn't miss a beat here.
但在家里，她脑子里想的都是那场枪击。那天的场景不断在她脑海中重演。桑迪在这里一点也没有错过节奏。
Over at the victims' assistance, they have trauma therapists over there. I recommend strongly that any of you kids really think about stopping by the victims' assistance--
在受害者援助中心那边有创伤治疗师。我强烈建议你们这些孩子真的考虑去受害者援助中心——
I will.
我会的。
--and do some trauma therapy. OK, honey.
——去做一些创伤治疗。好了，宝贝。
Thank you so much.
非常感谢。
You're welcome. You're welcome.
不客气。不客气。
The Phillipses don't make money off this. They're volunteers. And they're not wealthy either. They're retirees living in a 245-square-foot trailer, surviving off of modest savings and Social Security. Sandy is 68 and used to work in tourism for the city of San Antonio. And Lonnie is 74. He used to own some car lots.
菲利普斯夫妇并不靠这个赚钱。他们是志愿者。他们也不富有。他们是住在245平方英尺拖车里的退休人员，靠微薄的积蓄和社会保障金生活。桑迪今年68岁，以前在圣安东尼奥市从事旅游业。朗尼74岁。他以前拥有一些停车场。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
Please do. Let them know that we-- [INAUDIBLE]
请一定要去。让他们知道我们—— [听不清]
So have you guys met?
你们俩见面了吗？
Yes.
是的。
One thing I quickly realize going to Santa Fe is that there are now so many of these mass shootings that they become grim reunions for all the people who show up to them as part of their jobs or volunteer work.
我去圣达菲后很快意识到的一件事是，现在发生的大规模枪击事件太多了，以至于它们成了所有因为工作或志愿服务而来到这里的人的阴郁重聚。
Are you from Las Vegas?
你是从拉斯维加斯来的吗？
Sandy and Lonnie ran into an emergency responder from the Las Vegas shooting, and then bumped into this other guy who travels around, putting up all those white crosses you see at almost every mass shooting. He made one for their daughter, Jessi, in Aurora too. Standing on the patchy brown grass next to the crosses, Lonnie interrupted him to do this thing he and Sandy do a lot.
桑迪和朗尼遇到了拉斯维加斯枪击事件的一名应急响应人员，然后又撞见了另一个到处旅行的人，他负责安装你在几乎每一次大规模枪击事件中看到的那些白色十字架。他也为他们的女儿杰西在奥罗拉做了一个。站在十字架旁斑驳的棕色草地上，朗尼打断了他，去做他和桑迪经常做的这件事。
Sign-- 1:11.
标志——1:11。
They suddenly call out the time.
他们突然喊出了时间。
We have a 1:11 and 11:11, and we're talking to you at 1:11, so it's a sign from our daughter.
我们有1:11和11:11，现在是1:11，我们在和你说话，所以这是来自我们女儿的标志。
11:11 is a thing. A lot of people see it as an auspicious sign, or a time to make a wish. And it was a lyric in one of Jessi's favorite songs.
11:11是一个常见的说法。许多人认为这是一个吉祥的征兆，或者是许愿的时候。这也是杰西最喜欢的歌曲之一中的歌词。
So if we get 11:11 twice a day, we know we really had a good day.
所以如果我们一天能遇到两次11:11，我们知道我们这一天过得真的很好。
They told me, I know it's silly, but I take it as a hello or a God wink. It helps.
他们告诉我，我知道这很傻，但我把它当作一种问候或上帝的暗示。这很有帮助。
[INAUDIBLE] --
[听不清] ——
Hello.
你好。
--expect a double whammy in Denver.
——期待丹佛的双重打击。
What's your name?
你叫什么名字？
Cindy Evans.
辛迪·埃文斯。
Cindy? Cindy?
辛迪？辛迪？
My son was in the high school here.
我的儿子就在这所高中里。
Oh, I'm so sorry.
哦，我太抱歉了。
As the day went on, people kept dropping by the memorial in front of the high school. Parents and students stood huddled together, staring at the crosses or writing messages on them. It was quiet, and hot, and still. There was a low generator hum from the gigantic Billy Graham ministry truck set up in the parking lot. And then, all of a sudden, this young guy started wailing. Sandy made a beeline for him.
随着一天的推移，人们不断来到高中前的纪念地。家长和学生们聚集在一起，盯着十字架或在上面写下留言。那里很安静，很热，很平静。停车场里设置的巨大的葛培理布道车发出低沉的发电声。然后，突然，一个年轻小伙子开始嚎啕大哭。桑迪径直向他走去。
It's too much, man. It's too dang much. I'm sorry--
这太过了，伙计。这太过分了。对不起——
He immediately threw his arms around her.
他立刻搂住了她。
[INAUDIBLE] why this thing keeps happening.
[听不清] 为什么这事一直发生。
Oh, here, here, here, here, here. Put your arms around me.
哦，来，来，来，来，来。拥抱我。
[SOBBING]
[啜泣]
It's OK. It's OK-- it's not OK, it's not OK. Let it go, let it go, let it go, let it go, let it go. Just cry your heart out. Cry your heart out and get your anger out. I'm here. I'm here. I'm here.
没关系。没关系——不，没关系，没关系。发泄出来，发泄出来，发泄出来，发泄出来。尽情哭吧。尽情哭，把你的愤怒发泄出来。我在这儿。我在这儿。我在这儿。
[SOBBING]
[啜泣]
I'm so sorry. Oh, god, I'm so sorry.
我很抱歉。哦，上帝，我很抱歉。
It makes me wish I could have done something.
这让我希望我能做些什么。
OK. Yeah, it's OK, honey. You're doing it now. OK?
好了。是的，没关系，亲爱的。你现在就在做了。好吗？
He graduated last year. There were crosses set up for three people he knew well. One of them was a teacher named Ms. Perkins, who he really loved. He said she always tried to be strict with him, but could never keep up that front for very long.
他去年毕业。他认识的三个人有十字架，其中一个是帕金斯老师，他非常喜欢她。他说她总是试图对他严厉，但从来都坚持不了太久。
Just breathe. Take a nice, deep breath.
呼吸。做个深呼吸。
[SOBBING]
[啜泣]
Take a nice, deep breath.
做个深呼吸。
[SOB]
[啜泣]
OK. OK. Breathe with me.
好了。好了。跟我一起呼吸。
Thank you.
谢谢。
There you go.
就这样。
After a few minutes, he's caught his breath enough to talk. He tells Sandy he wants the shootings to stop. He wants to take action somehow. And then he suddenly switches gears and starts spilling out his feelings about guns and gun control.
几分钟后，他喘过气来，可以说话了。他告诉桑迪，他希望枪击事件停止。他想以某种方式采取行动。然后他突然转换话题，开始倾诉他对枪支和枪支管制的感受。
Nowadays, with the violence that is going on in this world, taking guns away is not going to change that. Because it's just like drugs. They make drugs illegal, and people are still able to get drugs.
如今，随着世界上正在发生的暴力事件，仅仅收缴枪支是不会改变现状的。因为它就像毒品一样。他们把毒品定为非法，但人们仍然可以得到毒品。
He plans to get a concealed handgun license when he turns 21 later this year.
他计划在今年晚些时候满21岁时获得隐藏携带手枪的执照。
The Phillips are actually gun owners too. They have a 12-gauge shotgun. They believe in the Second Amendment. But they're also advocates for universal background checks, and tight regulations on the types of guns, ammunition, and accessories-- like bump stocks-- a person can buy. However, Sandy says they don't push their political beliefs on survivors when they're doing outreach. Their primary goal is to support.
菲利普斯夫妇其实也是枪支拥有者。他们有一把12口径的霰弹枪。他们支持宪法第二修正案。但他们也是全民背景调查以及对个人可以购买的枪支、弹药和配件（如撞火枪托）进行严格监管的倡导者。然而，桑迪说，当他们进行外展活动时，他们不会向幸存者强加他们的政治信仰。他们的主要目标是支持。
But it's impossible for grieving parents to avoid the politics around guns. There's a whole movement of conspiracy theorists who believe that the US government stages mass shootings to make guns look bad.
但悲伤的父母不可能避开枪支政治。有一整套阴谋论者运动，认为美国政府策划了大规模枪击事件，使枪支看起来很糟糕。
We were told by Alex Jones that our daughter never existed.
亚历克斯·琼斯告诉我们，我们的女儿从未存在过。
Alex Jones, of course, is famous for saying that mass shootings are fake. He's now a defendant in several defamation lawsuits. When the Phillips ran into him face-to-face at a gun control event, he accused them of inventing their entire story.
亚历克斯·琼斯当然因为声称大规模枪击事件是虚假的而闻名。他现在是多起诽谤诉讼的被告。当菲利普斯夫妇在一次枪支管制活动中与他面对面时，他指责他们捏造了整个故事。
And then two minutes later, he's saying, your daughter's still alive, and she's living in the Bahamas, and she's living the high life, and you're crisis actors, and you're paid by the Obama administration, and da, da, da. And I'm listening to him, just going, you are so absolutely crazy.
然后两分钟后，他说，你的女儿还活着，她住在巴哈马群岛，过着奢华的生活，你们是危机演员，你们是奥巴马政府雇佣的，诸如此类。我听着他说话，心想，你真是疯透了。
Lonnie got into it with Jones, stood right in front of him. It looked like a shoving match was about to start, until Sandy stepped in and broke it up. I reached out to Jones through one of his lawyers, who declined to comment. The conspiracy theorists, known as truthers or hoaxers, troll families of victims on social media immediately after any mass shooting.
朗尼和琼斯对质，直接站在他面前。看起来一场推搡就要开始，直到桑迪介入并将其分开。我通过琼斯的一位律师联系了他，但他拒绝置评。这些被称为“真相揭露者”或“骗局制造者”的阴谋论者，在任何大规模枪击事件发生后，会立即在社交媒体上骚扰受害者家属。
This can get dangerous. After the Phillips' son gave interviews in Aurora, he got death threats and had to get the FBI involved. The man who was threatening him ended up in jail. So hoaxers are one of the things the Phillips warn parents about. They tell families to brace themselves.
这可能变得很危险。在菲利普斯的儿子在奥罗拉接受采访后，他收到了死亡威胁，不得不让联邦调查局介入。威胁他的那个人最终进了监狱。所以，骗局制造者是菲利普斯警告家长要注意的事情之一。他们告诉家庭要做好准备。
After watching Lonnie and Sandy in Santa Fe, I wondered why in the world they were throwing themselves back into this setting, reliving their worst moment over and over again. The answer, of course, starts with their daughter's shooting. They got the news in the middle of the night when they were asleep at their home in Texas.
在圣达菲观察完朗尼和桑迪后，我纳闷他们为什么还要把自己重新投入到这种环境中，一遍又一遍地重温他们最糟糕的时刻。答案当然是从他们女儿的枪击事件开始的。他们半夜在德克萨斯的家中睡觉时得到了消息。
This was back in 2012, and their daughter Jessi was in college at the time. She had gone to see the new Batman movie, The Dark Knight Rises, with one of her friends at a multiplex in Aurora, Colorado. About a half hour after the movie started, Jessi's friend called Sandy from the theater.
那是2012年，他们的女儿杰西当时正在上大学。她和她的一个朋友去科罗拉多州奥罗拉市的一个多厅影院看了新的蝙蝠侠电影《黑暗骑士崛起》。电影开始后大约半小时，杰西的朋友从剧院给桑迪打了电话。
The minute I picked up the phone there was [SIGHS] screaming-- just [SIGHS] horrible screaming in the background, and panic. And he said, there's been a shooting. And I was like, what is he talking about? Because Jessi had been at a mall in Toronto almost seven weeks before where there was a mass shooting.
我拿起电话的那一刻，背景里就有[叹息]尖叫——就是[叹息]可怕的尖叫和恐慌。他说，发生枪击了。我说，他在说什么？因为杰西在近七周前曾在多伦多的一家商场，那里也发生过大规模枪击事件。
This was a coincidence. Jessi had left a food court in a mall just three minutes before a man walked in and opened fire.
这是一个巧合。杰西在一名男子走进去开枪前三分钟离开了商场的美食广场。
So my first thought was, this isn't funny, you know. But he's not a prankster. And I said, are you OK? And he said, I think I've been hit twice.
所以我第一个想法是，这不好笑，你知道。但他不是个恶作剧者。我说，你没事吧？他说，我想我被击中了两次。
And it was when he said that that I went, why isn't Jessi calling? And I knew something was really wrong. He said, I tried.
就是在他说了那句话的时候，我意识到，为什么杰西不打电话？我知道出大事了。他说，我试过了。
And that's when I woke up, because the scream was so loud. It was so horrific and something I never heard before.
那是我清醒的时候，因为尖叫声太大了。太恐怖了，我以前从未听过。
Lonnie found Sandy in the living room, sliding down a wall. He picked her up and took her to their couch, where he held her. Jessi was one of 12 people killed that night. Another 70 people were injured.
朗尼在客厅里找到了桑迪，她正顺着墙壁滑下去。他抱起她，把她带到沙发上，紧紧抱着她。杰西是那天晚上遇难的12人之一。另外70人受伤。
And then, five months later, there was another mass shooting, Sandy Hook, where 20 first graders and six educators died.
五个月后，又发生了一起大规模枪击事件，桑迪胡克小学，20名一年级学生和6名教育工作者死亡。
Days later, the Brady Campaign to prevent gun violence contacted the Phillipses. They were reaching out to families from other mass shootings, and asked if they'd be willing to travel to Newtown to talk to parents there. Sandy said they didn't even have to think about it. They immediately said, yes, because they wished they'd had someone to talk to right after Jessi died.
几天后，预防枪支暴力布雷迪运动联系了菲利普斯夫妇。他们正在联系其他大规模枪击事件的家庭，询问他们是否愿意前往纽敦与那里的父母交谈。桑迪说他们甚至不需要考虑。他们立刻答应了，因为他们希望在杰西死后能有人和他们交谈。
But when they arrived at a community center in Newtown, Sandy says they felt nervous and uncomfortable. Maybe they were intruding. They weren't sure if these parents would feel angry or grateful about their presence.
但当他们到达纽敦的一个社区中心时，桑迪说他们感到紧张和不安。也许他们是在打扰。他们不确定这些父母会对他们的出现感到愤怒还是感激。
You know, it's like walking into a funeral of people that you don't know. And I remember saying to my husband when we walked in the room, and I saw their faces, and I said, that's what we looked like five months ago.
你知道，这就像走进一个你不认识的人的葬礼。我记得走进房间时对丈夫说，我看到了他们的脸，我说，五个月前我们看起来就是那样。
And what does that look like?
那是什么样的？
Pff. They're hanging on to each other. And they've been crying, so their eyes are red. They're walking almost robot-like. Their bodies are moving, but they're not really there.
噗。他们互相搀扶着。他们一直在哭，所以眼睛是红的。他们走路几乎像机器人一样。身体在动，但他们并没有真正活在当下。
I realized that's what I looked like just five months ago. But it also made me realize this is exactly what I want to be doing.
我意识到五个月前我看起来就是这样。但也让我意识到这正是我想要做的。
She wanted to help these parents acclimate to their new reality. Looking back, Sandy says it was probably too soon for them to be out there trying to comfort other parents when they were still so raw. But the Phillipses said there was also a strong and instant sense of kinship that they couldn't turn away from.
她想帮助这些父母适应他们的新现实。回首往事，桑迪说，当他们自己还处于巨大的创伤中时，去安慰其他父母可能太早了。但菲利普斯夫妇说，他们之间也有一种强烈而即时的亲属感，让他们无法拒绝。
While they were there, they ran into parents from other mass shootings too, parents from Virginia Tech and Tucson. These parents had lost kids suddenly and violently in places where they thought that they were safe. The Phillipses now had parents that they could lean on too.
当他们在那里时，他们也遇到了其他大规模枪击事件的父母，弗吉尼亚理工大学和图森的父母。这些父母的孩子都在他们认为安全的地方突然而暴力地失去了生命。菲利普斯夫妇现在也有了可以依靠的父母。
This was the moment that launched the Phillipses into what's become their life's work. They could see the need. There are no experts on what to do when your child dies in a mass shooting. The only experts are the people it's happened to.
这一刻开启了菲利普斯夫妇成为他们一生使命的工作。他们看到了需求。关于孩子在大规模枪击事件中死亡时该做什么，没有专家。唯一的专家就是经历过这种事的人。
So to help them find each other, Lonnie and Sandy have set up an organization, called Survivors Empowered. They help families navigate their grief, plus a bunch of other practical things, everything from medical bills, and charity scams that use kids photos to raise money, to how to get your child's body home if you live out of state. However, this new mission was hard for their family and friends to comprehend.
为了帮助他们找到彼此，朗尼和桑迪成立了一个名为“幸存者赋权”的组织。他们帮助家庭应对悲伤，以及处理一系列其他实际问题，从医疗账单、利用孩子照片进行筹款的慈善诈骗，到如果你住在外州该如何把孩子的遗体运回家。然而，他们的家人和朋友很难理解这个新使命。
They want you to move on with your life. They want you to get back to normal. My own brother said to me, he said, you're not the same as you were.
他们希望你继续生活。他们希望你回到正常状态。我自己的兄弟对我说，他说，你已经不是原来的你了。
I said, you know, let me explain something to you. You're right, I'm not the same person. I never will be. They see it as we're obsessed with this. Well, you know, we are, in a sense. We are obsessed with it.
我说，你知道，让我向你解释一下。你是对的，我不再是同一个人了。我也永远不会是了。他们认为我们对此着迷。好吧，你知道，从某种意义上说，我们确实着迷。我们确实着迷。
The Phillipses and a few other parents told me because it's so hard for people to understand that the grief never fades, old relationships start to fall away. People you were closest to disappear, which makes this informal support group even more crucial.
菲利普斯夫妇和其他一些父母告诉我，因为人们很难理解悲伤永远不会消退，旧的关系开始疏远。你最亲近的人消失了，这使得这个非正式的支持小组变得更加重要。
What that support looks like over time, and what it means to the parents who get it, I got to see all that when Sandy and Lonnie got to know a couple from Florida who lost their son in the shooting at Parkland-- Annika and Mitch Dworet. I met them at their house.
当桑迪和朗尼结识了一对来自佛罗里达州、在帕克兰枪击事件中失去儿子的夫妇——安妮卡和米奇·德沃雷特时，我得以看到这种支持随着时间的推移是什么样子的，以及它对得到支持的父母意味着什么。我在他们家见到了他们。
Their son's name was Nick. He was the captain of Parkland swim team and was about to go to the University of Indianapolis on a swim scholarship. He was a 6-foot-tall blond kid who collected different flavors of Oreos and waited for Supreme drops. Mitch said they'd just reached a point where they were becoming real friends. They talked about relationships, shared playlists, and watched Scarface together.
他们儿子的名字叫尼克。他是帕克兰游泳队的队长，即将凭借游泳奖学金进入印第安纳波利斯大学。他是一个6英尺高的金发男孩，收集各种口味的奥利奥，等待Supreme发售。米奇说他们刚刚达到了成为真正朋友的程度。他们谈论人际关系，分享播放列表，一起看《疤面煞星》。
The day of the shooting, Mitch and Annika got phone calls and texts all day from people who said they'd heard Nick was OK. One person said they heard he'd been moved to a staging area for all the students who witnessed the shooting. Another said a police officer was giving him a ride home. And then a nurse at a local hospital said she saw a patient who matched Nick's description.
枪击发生那天，米奇和安妮卡一整天都在接到人们的电话和短信，说他们听说尼克没事。一个人说他们听说他被转移到了一个安置点，那里安置了所有目击枪击的学生。另一个人说警察正送他回家。然后当地医院的一名护士说她看到了一个符合尼克描述的病人。
But by that evening, the Dworets still hadn't heard directly from Nick. So they went to a Marriott that law enforcement designated as a meeting area. They sat in a ballroom with other parents and waited.
但到了那天晚上，德沃雷特夫妇仍然没有直接收到尼克的消息。所以他们去了执法部门指定为会面地点的万豪酒店。他们坐在宴会厅里，和其他父母一起等待。
Every time the phone rings, you'd jump and think it's Nick calling from somebody else's phone. The media was calling you, do you have any comments? Can we help you find your son? And I was just like--
每次电话一响，你就会跳起来，以为是尼克用别人的电话打来的。媒体在打电话给你，你有什么评论吗？我们能帮你找到你的儿子吗？我只是觉得——
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
Yeah. And at 2 o'clock in the morning, we see this FBI car. And then they start pulling one family into rooms at a time. And you hear screams from these rooms.
是的。凌晨2点，我们看到了那辆联邦调查局的车。然后他们开始一次把一个家庭叫进房间。你听到这些房间里传出的尖叫声。
Then their names were called out.
然后他们的名字被叫到了。
Even walking into that room, you have this tiny little hope that they're going to say, like, we couldn't even find your son, you know. And that hope of that he was somewhere else. And I keep on thinking, maybe he walked home. And then you do the math in your head, like, it doesn't take that long to walk to our house.
即使走进那个房间，你也会怀着一丝小小的希望，希望他们会说，我们甚至找不到你的儿子，你知道。还有他可能在别处的希望。我一直想，也许他走回家了。然后在脑子里算算，走回家不需要那么久。
And then they told us the news, that he was gone. He was shot and he was never brought to the hospital at all. It was just like a nightmare. Just like a nightmare.
然后他们告诉了我们那个消息，他走了。他被枪杀了，根本没被送到医院。那就像一场噩梦。就像一场噩梦。
Nick's body was still at the school because he died instantly and the building was still a crime scene. It'd be two days before they could see him. Annika wanted to look at his injuries. Mitch did not.
尼克的尸体还在学校里，因为他当场死亡，大楼仍然是犯罪现场。两天后他们才能见到他。安妮卡想看看他的伤势。米奇不想。
Annika says this is just how her brain works. She's an ER nurse. She needs details. The director at the funeral home, wanting to protect her, called the medical examiner's office to ask about Nick.
安妮卡说这就是她大脑的运作方式。她是一名急诊室护士。她需要细节。殡仪馆馆长为了保护她，打电话给法医办公室询问尼克的情况。
And the person that answered the phone said, oh, let me-- let me take a look. What's the name again? It's Nicholas Dworet. He's the swimmer. Oh, the swimmer is perfect.
接电话的人说，噢，让我——让我看看。名字再说是哪一个？是尼古拉斯·德沃雷特。他是那个游泳运动员。哦，游泳运动员很完美。
What does that mean?
那是什么意思？
I think it meant that there was nothing on his face or his head. Like he was-- he was perfect.
我想那意味着他的脸或头上没有任何东西。就像他——他是完美的。
He'd been shot three times. A bullet in his chest destroyed his heart and lungs.
他被枪击了三次。一颗子弹击中胸部，摧毁了他的心脏和肺。
Was it helpful for you to see him?
见到他有帮助吗？
Yes, it was helpful. Because your picture in your head when you hear-- when you hear that somebody has been shot with an AR-15, just so gruesome, so horrible, horrible. And I think to see him, and to see on his body where his injuries were, made me get it. Like, he was so peaceful, and he was not in pain. And it made me have a better image of him than the one that was playing over in my mind.
是的，有帮助。因为当你听到——当你听到有人被AR-15击中时，脑海中的画面太可怕了，太恐怖了，太可怕了。我想见到他，看到他身体上的伤口在哪里，让我明白了。就像他很平静，没有痛苦。它让我对他有了一个比脑子里不断重演的画面更好的形象。
The Phillipses had traveled to Parkland a couple of days after the shooting. They didn't know the Dworets, but a mutual friend thought they should talk. And so this friend, with Mitch's permission, gave Sandy his phone number. Sandy called and got no answer. So she left a voicemail.
菲利普斯夫妇在枪击事件发生两天后前往了帕克兰。他们不认识德沃雷特夫妇，但一位共同的朋友认为他们应该谈谈。于是这位朋友在米奇的许可下，把他的电话号码给了桑迪。桑迪打了电话，无人接听。于是她留了语音留言。
I'm very sorry for your loss. I understand your loss. We lost our daughter. And you can call me any time.
对你的损失我感到非常抱歉。我理解你的损失。我们失去了女儿。你可以随时打给我。
She let him know that she and Lonnie would be in Parkland for a few more days. Mitch called back quickly. He did want to meet with them in person, thought it'd be helpful to talk to another family who'd been through a mass shooting. But he told Sandy the timing wasn't going to work. His house was packed with family in town for Nick's funeral.
她让他知道，她和朗尼会在帕克兰多待几天。米奇很快回了电话。他确实想亲自见见他们，认为和另一个经历过大规模枪击事件的家庭交谈会有帮助。但他告诉桑迪，时间不太凑巧。他的家里挤满了为尼克的葬礼而来的亲戚。
And I'm on the phone with him, and ironically, I'm standing right in front of his child's cross. And I said, you're not going to believe this.
我正在和他通电话，讽刺的是，我正站在他孩子十字架的正前方。我说，你不会相信这件事的。
She said that she was standing right in front of Nick's memorial. I get chills right now.
她说她正站在尼克的纪念碑前。我到现在还会起鸡皮疙瘩。
And we proceeded to have a talk. And he said, I don't think we're ready to meet with you. And I said, I totally understand. I'm just glad that we're getting to talk.
我们继续谈话。他说，我不认为我们准备好和你见面。我说，我完全理解。我很高兴我们能谈话。
But you do need to know that truthers are already online saying that this didn't happen. He said, what are truthers? And I said, ugh, OK.
但你需要知道，真相揭露者已经在网上说这并没有发生。他说，什么是真相揭露者？我说，啊，好吧。
I thought, like, wow, are you kidding me? Crazy.
我想，哇，你在开玩笑吗？疯了。
Mitch asked her to stop by their house the following day. While Mitch was on board with the Phillipses, Annika had a different take on total strangers stopping by their house.
米奇要求她第二天到他们家拜访。当米奇赞同菲利普斯夫妇时，安妮卡对素不相识的人上门拜访持不同看法。
I was more-- maybe more skeptical, like, nervous of why are they here, what's their agenda. How can people come and meet with us if they don't want something from us?
我当时可能——可能更怀疑，比如，紧张他们为什么要来，他们有什么企图。如果他们不是想要什么，怎么会有人来见我们？
Their house was so crowded that the only private place to talk was their bedroom. Annika and Mitch sat on the bed, Lonnie and Sandy in chairs. Annika remembers feeling a little uncomfortable and thinking to herself--
他们的房子太挤了，唯一能谈话的私密空间就是卧室。安妮卡和米奇坐在床上，朗尼和桑迪坐在椅子上。安妮卡记得当时感到有点不舒服，心里想——
Why am I sitting here? Why I'm not with the family? Who are these people? I don't know them. But I guess it might help.
为什么我坐在这里？为什么我不和家人在一起？这些人是谁？我不认识他们。但我猜这也许会有帮助。
But it was very overwhelming. Like, I can't believe that I have to sit and have this conversation. What is this? This is my life now?
但这非常令人不知所措。就像，我不敢相信我必须坐在这里进行这种对话。这是什么？这就是我现在的余生吗？
Was there a point in the conversation where it started to turn for you?
对话中有没有哪个点让你开始转变看法？
Yeah, I think-- I think when they said, don't join our organization now. Don't fight now. Just take care of yourself and let yourself grieve.
有，我想——我想是当他们说，现在不要加入我们的组织。现在不要去战斗。照顾好你自己，让自己去悲伤。
They asked questions about Nick. And before long, they were just talking.
他们问了关于尼克的问题。没过多久，他们就聊开了。
Lonnie remembers Mitch asking if they were religious and if they ever got signs from Jessi. He told Mitch that, like them, they weren't, but they took 11:11 as a hello from Jessi. The conversation went on for three hours.
朗尼记得米奇问他们是否有宗教信仰，是否从杰西那里得到过信号。他告诉米奇，像他们一样，他们没有，但他们把11:11看作杰西的问候。谈话持续了三个小时。
You know, all our friends and family, as much as they did for us and how much love they showed, none of them could have any clue what we were feeling. And here were two people knowing exactly what we were feeling.
你知道，我们的所有朋友和家人，尽管他们为我们做了很多，表达了多少爱，但他们都无法理解我们的感受。而这里有两个人，准确地知道我们的感受。
They also made me feel a little more confident. I don't know if that's the right word. You're in a club we all don't want to be in. We didn't want to meet you. We wish we would have met under different circumstances. But you have people who will help you with this kind of grief.
他们也让我感到更有信心了。我不知道这是否是正确的词。你加入了一个我们都不想加入的俱乐部。我们不想遇见你。我们希望我们是在不同的情况下相遇。但你有可以帮助你度过这种悲伤的人。
And a few days later, when the online conspiracies started appearing about Nick, that he didn't exist, or that he was living in California, they remembered Sandy's warning. It was still upsetting, but less upsetting because they knew it was coming.
几天后，当关于尼克的网络阴谋论开始出现，说他不存在，或者他住在加州时，他们想起了桑迪的警告。这仍然令人心烦，但因为知道它会来，所以也没那么心烦了。
They've helped in other ways too. The Dworets took the Phillipses' advice and got into trauma therapy right away, both individually and as a family.
他们也以其他方式提供了帮助。德沃雷特夫妇听取了菲利普斯夫妇的建议，立即进行了创伤治疗，无论是个人还是家庭。
Their younger son, Alex, has been through a lot. Nick was his best friend. One of the last things Nick did on the day of the shooting was walk Alex to his English class. Alex was injured in the shooting and sat by a kid who died right in front of him. Annika says managing her grief, along with her son's, has been tough.
他们的小儿子亚历克斯经历了很多。尼克是他最好的朋友。枪击那天尼克做的最后一件事之一就是送亚历克斯去上英语课。亚历克斯在枪击中受伤，坐在一个在他面前死去的小孩旁边。安妮卡说，管理她的悲伤和她儿子的悲伤一直很难。
There was so much attention on Nick, Nick, Nick, Nick, Nick. Everybody came for Nick. The flowers were for Nick, the letters were for Nick. I felt like, you know, I-- if this didn't happen to Nicholas, and only this, I could have been there for Alex so much stronger and so much more. So I was afraid that he would get neglected and all that.
所有的注意力都在尼克、尼克、尼克、尼克、尼克身上。所有人都为尼克而来。鲜花是给尼克的，信是给尼克的。我觉得，你知道，我——如果这件事没有发生在尼古拉斯身上，仅仅是这样，我可以更坚强地支持亚历克斯，做得更多。所以我担心他会被忽视，诸如此类。
I think sometimes children feel like, well, you must have loved that child more than you love me.
我觉得有时候孩子们会觉得，好吧，你一定比爱我更爱那个孩子。
Sandy's son was 25 when his sister died. Sandy tried to talk to him about it, which ended up pushing him farther away. When she talks to parents, she talks about her own mistakes too.
桑迪的儿子在妹妹去世时是25岁。桑迪试图和他谈论这件事，但这最终把他推得更远。当她和父母谈话时，她也谈到了她自己的错误。
Eight months after they first met, Mitch is still in touch with Sandy. They text or call each other every couple weeks. Mitch relies on Sandy more than Annika, who, unlike him, already has a built-in network of friends she talks to all the time.
第一次见面八个月后，米奇仍然和桑迪保持联系。他们每隔几周就发短信或通电话。米奇比安妮卡更依赖桑迪，安妮卡和米奇不同，她已经有一个一直都在交谈的固定朋友网络。
And we texted-- I think we texted yesterday. It was 11:11, actually. We texted yesterday.
我们发短信了——我想我们昨天发了短信。实际上是11:11。我们昨天发了短信。
And I feel like she's still in it. She's still with us. She's-- it's someone who we can lean on and give us support. And I, in turn, wanted her to lean on me. Maybe, you know, seeing us get stronger, it gives her energy too.
我觉得她还在里面。她仍然和我们在一起。她是——是可以依靠并给予我们支持的人。而我，反过来，也想让她依靠我。也许，你知道，看到我们变得更坚强，这也给了她能量。
He's right about that. Sandy spends almost every day at her tiny kitchen table in their trailer fielding texts and phone calls from survivors, and messaging with people on social media who ask for help.
他说得对。桑迪几乎每天都坐在拖车里那张小小的餐桌前，处理幸存者的短信和电话，并在社交媒体上与寻求帮助的人交流。
And the pain is always there at the end of the day and when you go to bed at night. And when you first wake up in the morning it's there. But you have a sense of purpose, and that-- that helps.
痛苦在一天结束时、晚上睡觉前总是存在的。当你早上醒来时它也在。但你有一种目标感，那——那会有所帮助。
A little bit of a lifeline or something?
是一种小小的救命稻草之类的东西吗？
Oh, it's a total lifeline-- total. If I didn't have this work, I don't think I'd be alive. I really don't.
哦，那绝对是救命稻草——绝对的。如果我没有这份工作，我觉得我活不下去。我真的不觉得。
And I say that to Lonnie all the time. And he goes, but, you know, don't you love me enough, kind of thing, to stay alive? I just don't think I would have had the ability to keep going.
我一直对朗尼说。他会说，但是，你知道，你不够爱我吗，之类的，为了活下去？我只是觉得我没有能力继续前行了。
Mitch and Annika told me that when they're feeling stronger, they'd like to do for other families with the Phillipses have done for them. They said, god forbid another shooting happens. But if it does, we'll be out there with them.
米奇和安妮卡告诉我，当他们感到更坚强时，他们也愿意为其他家庭做菲利普斯夫妇为他们做过的事。他们说，上帝保佑不要再发生枪击事件。但如果发生了，我们会和他们一起去。
Miki Meek is one of the producers of our show.
米奇·米克是我们节目的制片人之一。
Coming up, a parent tries to combat an infuriating and very personal piece of misinformation online that just will not go away, and does some things that parents almost never do. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，一位家长试图打击网上一个令人愤怒且非常个人化的、怎么也消不掉的错误信息，并做了一些家长几乎从不做的举动。那是一分钟后的事，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, the parents step in.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在我们的节目中，父母们采取了行动。
So with the government doing-- I don't know-- is it nothing?; is it next to nothing?-- to reduce the number of mass shootings in this country, we have stories today of parents taking action, specifically parents of children who were killed in mass shootings. And in the stories we have in today's show, these parents, they get results.
所以，由于政府做得——我不知道——是无所作为吗？还是近乎无所作为？——来减少这个国家大规模枪击事件的数量，我们今天报道的故事是父母们在采取行动，特别是那些在大规模枪击事件中失去孩子的父母。而在今天节目的故事中，这些父母，他们取得了成果。
The dad in this next act is somebody who Lonnie and Sandy introduced producer Miki Meek to. His name is Lenny Pozner. This is Act Two of our show, "Down the Rabbit Hole."
下一幕中的父亲是朗尼和桑迪向制片人米奇·米克介绍的。他的名字是莱尼·波兹纳。这是我们节目的第二幕，“掉进兔子洞”。
And when Lenny Pozner wants to explain to people what his life is like, he sometimes tells this story. On election night back in 2016, he says he went to a bar, got a seat near a television, ordered a beer, and you know, started making small talk.
当莱尼·波兹纳想要向人们解释他的生活是什么样时，他有时会讲这个故事。2016年大选之夜，他说他去了酒吧，在电视机旁找了个位子，点了一杯啤酒，然后你知道，开始闲聊。
And I had turned to the guy to my right, and I said, did you vote? And from there, he went into a long explanation about just some shadow government ideas, and whether voting makes a difference. And probably 10 minutes into it he was talking about mass shootings, and then eventually Sandy Hook.
我转向右边的那个人，我说，你投票了吗？从那里开始，他进行了一长串的解释，关于一些影子政府的想法，以及投票是否有影响。大约十分钟后，他开始谈论大规模枪击事件，然后最终谈到了桑迪胡克。
Sandy Hook, of course, where a gunman killed 20 children, all in first grade, as well as seven adults.
桑迪胡克当然是那个发生枪击事件的地方，一名枪手杀害了20名孩子，全是一年级的，还有7名成年人。
This random stranger then started telling Lenny this particular story about Sandy Hook. He thought the whole shooting was fake. It had to be fake, he said, because one of those first graders also showed up as a victim in a second mass shooting, all the way over in Pakistan. In the corners of the internet, where people trade Sandy Hook conspiracy theories, this is a key piece of evidence that Sandy Hook wasn't real.
这个随机的陌生人然后开始告诉莱尼关于桑迪胡克的那个特定故事。他认为整个枪击事件都是假的。一定是假的，他说，因为其中一个一年级学生也出现在远在巴基斯坦的另一起大规模枪击事件中。在互联网的角落里，人们交易桑迪胡克的阴谋论，这是桑迪胡克不是真实的证据的关键部分。
Of course, it was real. And what happened in Pakistan was, in reality, about two years after Sandy Hook, the Taliban gunned down more than 100 kids there. And there was a public vigil. And at the public vigil, probably as a sign of solidarity with other kids who had died in school shootings, mourners had this photo of a boy from Sandy Hook, smiling and wearing a Spider-Man shirt under a corduroy jacket with a furry collar. Sandy Hook deniers saw that in the coverage, and they pounced. Did he die twice? Did he die at all?
当然，它是真实的。在巴基斯坦发生的事情实际上是在桑迪胡克事件大约两年后，塔利班在那里枪杀了100多名孩子。当时举行了公开守夜活动。在公开守夜活动上，可能是为了表达对其他在校园枪击中遇难孩子的声援，哀悼者拿着这张来自桑迪胡克的照片，照片上的男孩微笑着，穿着带有皮毛领的灯芯绒夹克，里面是蜘蛛侠T恤。桑迪胡克的否定者在报道中看到了这一点，他们扑了上来。他死过两次吗？他真的死过吗？
So the guy at the bar with Lenny is rattling through all this Pakistan stuff. And then, as Lenny explained to Miki Meek, who he told this story to, the guy mentions the kid's name-- Noah Pozner.
所以酒吧里和莱尼在一起的那个人在滔滔不绝地说所有这些巴基斯坦的东西。然后，正如莱尼向米奇·米克解释的那样，他把这个故事告诉了她，那个人提到了孩子的名字——诺亚·波兹纳。
I didn't really need to hear much more than that. I just needed to shut him down, basically.
我真的不需要听太多。我基本上只需要让他闭嘴。
So what did you do?
那你做了什么？
I took out my driver's license. And I said, look who you're talking to. Show some respect.
我掏出了我的驾照。我说，看看你在和谁说话。表现出一点尊重。
The boy in the photo was Lenny's son, Noah, who was six when he died.
照片中的男孩是莱尼的儿子诺亚，死时六岁。
Does he connect it, or--?
他联系起来了吗，还是——？
Well, sure, he connected it instantly, yeah. And he just became more agitated, very angered, and went outside and maybe had a cigarette. Came back, yelled at me some more. Oh, my god, how much did they pay you? How can you do this? He was committed to his belief. I was the villain.
好吧，当然，他立刻联系起来了，是的。他变得更加激动，非常愤怒，走到外面也许抽了根烟。回来后又对我大喊大叫。噢，上帝，他们付给你多少钱？你怎么能这么做？他致力于他的信仰。我成了恶棍。
People like this man at the bar pretty much redefined everything about the way Lenny lives his life-- where he lives, how he lives. He runs into these hoaxers in person and pretty much every day online. They think the government has paid him millions to play the part of a grieving dad. In their minds, Lenny is the sick one. Noah was never even his kid.
像酒吧里这个男人这样的人几乎重新定义了莱尼生活方式的一切——他住在哪里，他如何生活。他几乎每天都在网上亲身遇到这些骗局制造者。他们认为政府付给他数百万美元来扮演一个悲伤的父亲的角色。在他们看来，莱尼才是那个有病的人。诺亚甚至从未是他的孩子。
And the person who has popularized these theories more than anybody is Alex Jones, who runs the website Infowars, and who pushed these theories with his radio show and his YouTube videos.
而比任何人都更推广这些理论的人是亚历克斯·琼斯，他经营着Infowars网站，并通过他的广播节目和YouTube视频推动这些理论。
Alex Jones made his name right after 9/11, promoting the idea that 9/11 was an attack orchestrated by our own government. With Sandy Hook, Jones said many times that he did not believe the shooting was real.
亚历克斯·琼斯在9/11事件后立即声名鹊起，宣扬9/11是咱们自己政府策划的袭击这一想法。对于桑迪胡克，琼斯多次表示他不相信这次枪击是真实的。
Sandy Hook is a synthetic, completely fake, with actors, in my view, manufactured. I couldn't believe it at first. I knew they had actors there, clearly. But I thought they killed some real kids. And it just shows how bold they are that they clearly used actors.
在我看来，桑迪胡克是合成的、完全虚假的，有演员，制造出来的。起初我不敢相信。我知道他们在那里用了演员。但我以为他们确实杀了几个真实的孩子。这正好说明他们有多大胆，因为他们明确使用了演员。
He's claimed that the government, or some shadowy global forces, are the ones who hired these actors. He and the other hoaxers call them crisis actors. It's like this whole alternate world that exists right next to the real one. It makes life miserable for parents like Lenny.
他声称政府，或者某些阴暗的全球力量，才是雇佣这些演员的人。他和那些骗局制造者称他们为危机演员。这就像存在于现实世界旁边的整个平行世界。这让像莱尼这样的父母的生活很悲惨。
But unlike most parents in that situation, Lenny decided to go all action hero on the hoaxers and on Alex Jones. Action hero, I will do what needs to get done to defend my family-- damn the consequences. Lenny is resourceful. He is dogged. He does not give up. In this world that we live in of hoaxers and trolls, he's marked out a path that I think very few of us would want to take.
但与那种情况下的大多数父母不同，莱尼决定在骗局制造者和亚历克斯·琼斯面前变成动作英雄。动作英雄，我将做需要做的事情来保护我的家庭——管他什么后果。莱尼足智多谋。他很顽强。他从不放弃。在我们生活的这个充满骗局制造者和网络喷子的世界里，他走出了一条我认为我们很少有人愿意走的路。
Miki Meek, who did the story on Sandy and Lonnie also put together this story about the transformation of Lenny Pozner. We first broadcast this back in 2019. There are some curse words in the story that we have un-beeped for this podcast version of the show. If you prefer a beeped version, go to our website. Here's Miki.
米奇·米克，那位做关于桑迪和朗尼故事的人，也制作了这个关于莱尼·波兹纳转变的故事。我们第一次在2019年播出这个节目。故事里有一些咒骂的话，我们在本节目的播客版本中没有消音。如果你更喜欢消音版本，去我们的网站。这是米奇。
The first time Lenny became aware of any conspiracy theories about Sandy Hook was about a month after the shooting. He'd been on a media blackout, trying to get through Noah's funeral, and taking care of his two young girls. They were also at the elementary school that morning. And one of them was Noah's twin sister. She hid in a separate classroom.
莱尼第一次意识到关于桑迪胡克的任何阴谋论是在枪击事件发生大约一个月后。他一直处于媒体封锁状态，试图度过诺亚的葬礼，照顾他的两个年幼的女儿。那天早上她们也在那所小学。其中一个是诺亚的双胞胎姐妹。她躲在另一间教室里。
But one day, Lenny finally felt ready to go online, read the news, googled his son's name.
但有一天，莱尼终于觉得准备好上网，读新闻，谷歌了他儿子的名字。
Infowars was coming up on search results, the forums.
Infowars出现在搜索结果中，论坛也是。
The forums were.
论坛也是。
Yeah, and it's just completely disgusting.
是的，这简直令人作呕。
In just over 30 days, this whole world had been invented. And one of the central pieces of it involved Lenny's wife. Infowars fans were dissecting this one interview she did on CNN. It was with Anderson Cooper, just days after Noah's funeral.
在短短30多天的时间里，整个世界就被编造出来了。其中一个核心部分涉及莱尼的妻子。Infowars的粉丝们在剖析她在CNN做的那次采访。那是安德森·库珀做的，就在诺亚葬礼后的几天。
What do you want people to know about Noah?
你想要人们知道关于诺亚的什么？
He loved running and playing with his siblings. And he loved bubble baths and fireflies. And he loved eating the inside of Oreo cookies. And he played the video "Gangnam Style" ad nauseam.
他喜欢跑步和与兄弟姐妹玩耍。他喜欢泡泡浴和萤火虫。他喜欢吃奥利奥饼干的内馅。他不停地播放“江南Style”的视频。
I understand he used to tell his siblings that he-- that he managed a taco factory.
我听说他过去常告诉他的兄弟姐妹说他——他经营着一家玉米饼工厂。
Yes, he was going to split his time as an adult between managing a taco factory and being an astronaut.
是的，他打算长大后把时间分配在经营一家玉米饼工厂和当宇航员之间。
The comments online were gross and flimsy. Why didn't she sound sadder? Why would she put on lipstick if she was really grieving? And wasn't she too old to be the mom of a six-year-old kid? They were convinced that something was up.
网上的评论很恶心，很薄弱。为什么她听起来不那么悲伤？如果她真的在悲伤，为什么要涂口红？而且作为一个六岁孩子的妈妈，她是不是太老了？他们确信一定出了什么问题。
How are you holding up? I mean--
你还好吗？我是说——
Most of the time, I'm kind of numb. I think every mom out there can relate to the fact of how long it takes to create a baby, those nine months, that you watch every ultrasound and every heartbeat. And it takes nine months to create a human being, and it takes seconds for an AR-15 to take that away from the surface of this earth.
大多数时候，我有点麻木。我想每个妈妈都能感同身受，创造一个宝宝需要多长时间，那九个月，你看着每一次超声波和每一次心跳。创造一个人需要九个月，而AR-15从这个地球表面夺走那个生命只需要几秒钟。
This reference to guns was another aha moment for conspiracy theorists. Some of them started digging into Veronique's life, looked up her maiden name, and then said, hey, look at this. There's a Swiss diplomat who has her exact same name. And even fishier, this diplomat once went to an arms control summit at the United Nations.
这个对枪支的提及是阴谋论者的又一个“啊哈”时刻。他们中的一些人开始挖掘维罗妮克的过去，查了她的婚前姓，然后说，嘿，看看这个。有一个和她名字完全一样的瑞士外交官。更可疑的是，这个外交官曾经参加过联合国的一次军控峰会。
So maybe they're the same person. Maybe she's one of those elite globalists, trying to make guns look bad so President Obama can repeal the Second Amendment. Suddenly, every real sentiment Veronique shared about Noah was getting reinterpreted as lines from a sinister script.
所以也许他们是同一个人。也许她是那些精英全球主义者之一，试图让枪支看起来很糟糕，这样奥巴马总统就可以废除第二修正案。突然间，维罗妮克分享的关于诺亚的每一个真实情感都被重新解释为邪恶剧本中的台词。
They were here and they mattered. They all had families. And they matter.
他们曾经在这里，他们很重要。他们都有家人。他们很重要。
And the kicker that cinched it for these conspiracy theorists-- Anderson Cooper's nose. There's this moment when the tip of his nose disappears because of a digital glitch in the video, what CNN says was normal interference that happens with a live satellite feed. It's just a couple seconds, but hoaxers wouldn't let it go.
而那些阴谋论者的最后临门一脚——安德森·库珀的鼻子。有一个时刻，因为视频中的数字故障，他的鼻尖消失了，CNN称这是直播卫星馈送中发生的正常干扰。只有几秒钟，但骗局制造者就是不放过它。
And they said that it's a green screen, or a blue screen, or whatever. So that was a fake interview, and Veronique was a participant of a fake, staged CNN interview. That conspiracy theory was all over YouTube, and it was all over YouTube with Noah's image.
他们说那是绿屏，或蓝屏，或其他什么。所以那是一个虚假的采访，维罗妮克是一个虚假、精心策划的CNN采访的参与者。那个阴谋论到处都是，YouTube上到处都是，诺亚的形象到处都是。
I've talked to parents who've lost kids in other mass shootings, and they've all been blindsided by online harassment from conspiracy theorists. The crisis actor claim is so common now, these attacks usually start almost immediately after victims are IDed in the media. And parents who go on TV and talk about gun control, like Veronique, they get it the worst.
我和在其他大规模枪击事件中失去孩子的父母谈过，他们都被阴谋论者的网络骚扰搞得措手不及。危机演员的说法现在太普遍了，这些攻击通常在受害者身份在媒体上确认后几乎立即开始。而那些上电视谈论枪支管制的父母，像维罗妮克那样，遭到的攻击最严重。
Sandy Hook is when this really took off. Families get stuck fending off all this crazy hate by themselves. There just aren't that many resources for them, because law enforcement still hasn't figured out how to deal with most cyber harassment. And the tech companies aren't much help.
桑迪胡克是这件事真正腾飞的时候。家庭陷入了独自抵御所有这些疯狂仇恨的境地。对他们来说资源太少了，因为执法部门还没弄清楚如何处理大多数网络骚扰。科技公司也没什么帮助。
So most families just try to ignore the conspiracy theorists and hope they'll eventually go away. And that's what Lenny did for a while. His life was a wreck.
所以大多数家庭只是试图无视阴谋论者，希望他们最终会消失。这正是莱尼一段时间里所做的。他的生活是一片废墟。
But after about a year and a half, they were still at it. And he couldn't let it go anymore.
但大约一年半后，他们仍然在这样做。他再也无法放手了。
And I realized that grieving requires a calmness and a silence. And all of this material was a distraction for me, and it was noise. And I needed to handle that noise so that I could have the silence and calm that I needed.
我意识到悲伤需要宁静和沉默。所有这些素材对我来说都是一种干扰，那是噪音。我需要处理那些噪音，以便我可以拥有我需要的宁静和平静。
There's this photo I love of Lenny, with his arm wrapped around Noah. He's got a walrus mustache and he's kneeling on a trampoline with a soft smile. It's spring. And Noah has all this big brown hair, fat cheeks. He's snuggling his whole body into Lenny's chest.
有一张我很喜欢的莱尼的照片，他的手臂搂着诺亚。他留着海象胡子，跪在蹦床上，带着温柔的微笑。那是春天。诺亚有着浓密的棕色头发，胖乎乎的脸颊。他把整个身体蜷缩在莱尼的怀里。
Lenny's got tons of family photos like these. He posted them in an online memorial he made for Noah right after he died.
莱尼有很多这样的家庭照片。他把这些照片发布在他去世后为诺亚制作的网上纪念碑里。
But Sandy Hook deniers downloaded them and repurposed them into cruel memes, wrote "fake" across Noah's face. Took a picture of his headstone and photoshopped under his name, "Is not buried here." Photos of his daughters were circulating too.
但桑迪胡克的否定者下载了它们，把它们重新利用成残酷的表情包，在诺亚的脸上写上“假的”。拍下他墓碑的照片，并在名字下方用Photoshop写上“没埋在这里”。他女儿的照片也在流传。
He couldn't just leave them out there on the web with the trolls. Lenny got consumed with thinking about how to take control of the situation, how to extract Noah and his family from all this.
他不能就这样把它们留在网络上，让喷子们随意摆布。莱尼全身心投入到思考如何控制局面，如何把诺亚和他的家庭从这一切中解救出来。
The internet didn't scare him. It was actually his comfort zone. He ran his own IT business. He was not the kind of guy who sat around and complained about how something didn't work. He was a guy who fixed stuff.
互联网并没有吓倒他。这实际上是他的舒适区。他经营着自己的IT生意。他不是那种坐着抱怨事情为什么没用的那种人。他是那种修复问题的人。
So you need to find what the problem is, and then find you know what your solution is, and then start getting closer to that solution step by step. Otherwise, the problem is overwhelming, and then you just want someone else to fix it for you. You have to track down where you can make a difference and get closer to being less broken.
所以你需要找到问题所在，然后找到解决方案，然后一步步接近那个解决方案。否则，问题会让人不知所措，然后你只会想让别人为你修复它。你必须追踪你在哪里可以做出改变，并离不再那么破碎更近一步。
There was one other thing that made Lenny especially qualified to deal with the conspiracy theorists. He used to enjoy those theories himself, the classic fun ones-- Bigfoot, Loch Ness, Area 51, NASA faking the moon landing.
还有另一件事使莱尼特别有资格处理阴谋论者。他过去自己也喜欢那些理论，经典的有趣的那些——大脚怪、尼斯湖水怪、51区、NASA伪造登月。
Like, what's the fun of it?
比如，那有什么乐趣？
It's suspending your disbelief. It's like sitting down and watching a science fiction movie and then looking at the "what if?" And it's just fun-- especially if there's no price to pay in your life, and there's no cost to that way of thinking. Then it's just a game.
那是搁置你的怀疑。这就像坐下来看一部科幻电影，然后看着“如果会怎样？”这很有趣——特别是如果你的生活中不需要为此付出代价，也没有那种思维方式的成本。那它就只是一场游戏。
Sometimes he even listened to Alex Jones in his car. And in fact, just a month after the shootings, when Lenny first saw those things on Alex Jones's website, he tried to reach out. He found a general Infowars email address and shot him off this message.
有时他甚至在车里听亚历克斯·琼斯的节目。事实上，就在枪击发生一个月后，当莱尼第一次在他的网站上看到那些东西时，他尝试过联系。他找到了Infowars的通用电子邮件地址，发出了这条信息。
"Alex, I'm very disappointed to see how many people are directing more anger at families that lost their children in Newtown, accusing us of being actors. Haven't we had our share of pain and suffering? I used to enjoy listening to your shows. Now I feel that your type of show created these hateful people, and they need to be reeled in!" Exclamation point. About an hour later, he heard back from Jones's staff.
“亚历克斯，我非常失望地看到这么多人把更多的愤怒指向那些在纽敦失去孩子的家庭，指责我们是演员。我们的痛苦和苦难还不够多吗？我过去喜欢听你的节目。现在我觉得你的这类节目制造了这些可恨的人，他们需要被收敛！”感叹号。大约一个小时后，他收到了琼斯工作人员的回信。
And they responded with, "We have not supported the crisis actor claim. We insist that it's a true event." And on and on.
他们回应说：“我们不支持危机演员的说法。我们坚持认为这是一个真实的事件。”诸如此类。
This wasn't true. Jones did spread the crisis actor theory. It was on his website at the time. And he started talking about it-- a lot. That CNN interview with Veronique, he talked about it all the time.
这不是真的。琼斯确实传播了危机演员的理论。当时它就在他的网站上。他开始谈论它——很多。那次维罗妮克的CNN采访，他一直谈论它。
Folks, we've got video of Anderson Cooper with clear blue screen out there. He's not there in the town square. We've got people clearly coming up and laughing and then doing the fake crying. We've clearly got people where it's actors playing different parts of different people.
各位，我们有安德森·库珀的视频，外面有清晰的蓝屏。他不在镇广场上。我们有人们明显走上前去大笑，然后假装哭泣。我们很明显有人们在那里作为演员扮演不同的人的不同角色。
I've looked at it, and undoubtedly there's a cover-up. There's actors. They're manipulating. And they've been caught lying. And they were pre-planning before it and rolled out with it.
我看过它，毫无疑问有掩盖。有演员。他们在操纵。他们被抓到撒谎。他们在它发生前就预先计划好，然后随之发布。
What Lenny wanted was a one-on-one conversation with Jones. But it didn't happen.
莱尼想要的是和琼斯进行一对一的对话。但没发生。
There were a few emails after that asking me to prove that I'm really who I am, and sort of leading on to get me on the show.
在那之后有几封邮件要求我证明我真的是谁，并引导我上节目。
Lenny didn't want that. He's very private and very reserved, a behind-the-scenes kind of guy. He's careful when he talks-- things like, no comment, that's off the record, or do I have to talk about my personal life? That came up all the time during our interview.
莱尼不想那样。他非常私密且非常保守，是个幕后的人。他说话很谨慎——像“不予置评”、“那是非正式的”或者“我一定要谈论我的个人生活吗？”那种话在他的采访中一直出现。
One of the ground rules he gave is that I had to run his quotes past him and his lawyer, because he's worried about his own safety if his words were misconstrued. Also, he's fighting some of the conspiracy theorists in court.
他给出的基本规则之一是我必须把他的引文拿给他和他的律师看，因为他担心如果他的话被曲解，他自己的安全会受到影响。而且，他正在法庭上与一些阴谋论者斗争。
We agreed to his terms, and in the end, he didn't ask me to edit any of his quotes. But he did request that we remove one personal detail, and we did.
我们同意了他的条款，最终，他没有要求我编辑他的任何引文。但他确实要求我们删除一个个人细节，我们删了。
Now, a year and a half after he reached out to Alex Jones, he decided to try a new tactic. He'd go directly to Jones's followers and the other Sandy Hook conspiracy theorists.
现在，在他联系亚历克斯·琼斯一年半后，他决定尝试一种新的策略。他要直接找琼斯的追随者和其他桑迪胡克的阴谋论者。
I think his approach was, I'm going to make them see the light.
我想他的策略是，我要让他们看到光明。
This is Veronique. She and Lenny were separated when the shooting happened, but were still very much in each other's lives. They decided to start releasing documents about Noah-- report cards, school photos.
这是维罗妮克。当枪击事件发生时，她和莱尼分居了，但仍然非常深入地参与彼此的生活。他们决定开始公布关于诺亚的文件——成绩单、学校照片。
He even disclosed Noah's death certificate, which was a difficult decision that we made. But figured after a while of providing this hard copy, convincing evidence that reason would prevail. And they would say, oh, OK, yeah, you've made your point, I'm going to come around.
他甚至披露了诺亚的死亡证明，这是我们做出的一个艰难决定。但我们认为在提供这份硬拷贝、令人信服的证据一段时间后，理性会占上风。他们会说，哦，好的，是的，你已经说服我了，我会改变观点的。
Lenny also decided he'd answer anyone's questions. He wanted to join this notorious Facebook group called "Sandy Hook Hoax." It's where a lot of the deniers were congregating and sharing theories. The cover photo on their page looked like it came straight out of a horror movie-- a corpse-like girl with a "keep quiet" finger in front of her mouth. The administrator of the Facebook group immediately let him in.
莱尼还决定回答任何人的问题。他想加入这个臭名昭著的Facebook小组，叫“桑迪胡克骗局”。这是许多否定者聚集在一起分享理论的地方。他们主页上的封面照片看起来像是直接从恐怖电影里出来的——一个尸体般的女孩，手指放在嘴前示意“保持安静”。该Facebook小组的管理员立刻让他进去了。
Did you identify yourself as, like, I am a father?
你是否有确认你的身份，比如，我是一个父亲？
They knew who I was. They knew who I was instantly, yeah.
他们知道我是谁。他们立刻知道我是谁，是的。
Like to me, it seems so crazy to even go there. Like, this doesn't exactly sound like a group of people who'd want to listen to you.
比如对我来说，即使去那里似乎也很疯狂。比如，这听起来不太像是那种想要听你说话的人群。
People who are conspiracy minded, see these tragedies unfold on the internet or on television, they still feel separate from these events. And I considered that bridging that gap could be an important step.
持有阴谋论思维的人，在互联网或电视上看着这些悲剧展开，仍然感到自己与这些事件无关。我考虑到弥合这种鸿沟可能是一个重要的步骤。
So that I can add a human element to this.
这样我就可以为这件事增加一个人文元素。
That's right. That's right. And so here I am. I'm the person. And so let's see what happens.
是对的。是对的。所以我就在这里。我就是那个人。所以让我们看看会发生什么。
The questions started pouring in.
问题开始接踵而至。
"Why weren't these children rushed to hospitals?" "Why wasn't anything done?" Why aren't you suing the EMTs?" Or "Why aren't you doing this?" "Why wasn't a rescue helicopter called from Hartford?" And I started to recognize some of the patterns that were there.
“为什么这些孩子没有被送到医院？”“为什么什么都没做？”“为什么你不起诉急救人员？”或者“为什么你不这样做？”“为什么没有从哈特福德呼叫救援直升机？”我开始识别出那里的一些模式。
There were the people you'd expect in a conspiracy group-- anti-gun control people, anti-government people, but also parents.
那里有你预期会在阴谋论组织里见到的人——反对枪支管制的人，反政府的人，但也包括父母。
They were young parents with small children. And they just couldn't wrap their minds around the reality that an adult can look at children in their eyes and pump bullets into their head. They just can't deal with that.
他们是带着小孩的年轻父母。他们只是无法理解这样一个现实：一个成年人可以看着孩子的眼睛，把子弹射进他们的头颅。他们就是无法面对那个现实。
The conversation on this Facebook group quickly got ugly and abusive. Some of the members started using antisemitic slurs. Lenny was trying everything to keep up a rapport with them. He even told them, I listen to Alex Jones in my car. I used to argue with people about 9/11 being an inside job. I entertained that we didn't go to the moon.
这个Facebook小组上的对话很快变得丑陋和辱骂。一些成员开始使用反犹太主义的诋毁词汇。莱尼试图尽一切努力与他们保持融洽的关系。他甚至告诉他们，我在车里听亚历克斯·琼斯。我过去常和别人争论9/11是内部工作。我甚至娱乐过我们没有登上月球的想法。
But it didn't work. So he started blocking people and fighting back. This got him booted from the group.
但没用。所以他开始屏蔽人们并进行反击。这让他被踢出了小组。
What's remarkable is just how up for this whole fight he was. When a bunch of people kept private messaging him, Lenny thought, you know what, I'll just start my own Facebook group. He called it "Conspiracy Theorists Anonymous." This name was meant as a joke. He has a dry sense of humor.
令人瞩目的是他为整场斗争做好了多么充分的准备。当一群人不断私信他时，莱尼想，你知道吗，我就创建我自己的Facebook小组。他叫它“阴谋论者匿名”。这个名字是开玩笑的。他有一种冷幽默。
Anyway, he made some progress with people-- the people who weren't full-blown deniers, who actually wanted help parsing out the truth of what really happened. But they dropped away once they got answers. And pretty soon, the only ones left were just dark, sadistic trolls coming in to entertain themselves.
总之，他在人们身上取得了一些进展——那些不是完全彻底的否定者，那些实际上想要帮助梳理出到底发生了什么真相的人。但当他们得到答案后就离开了。很快，剩下的只有阴暗、虐待狂般的喷子进来取乐。
One of Lenny's worst trolls was a guy named Wolfgang Halbig. That's his real name, by the way. He's a retired school security expert in Florida, who's probably the number one Newtown hoaxer in the world. This guy travels to Newtown, appeared as an expert on Alex Jones's show. He's even called for Newtown parents to exhume the bodies of their children to prove that they're dead.
莱尼最糟糕的喷子之一是一个叫沃尔夫冈·哈尔比格的人。顺便说一下，那是他的真名。他是一名退休的佛罗里达学校安全专家，可能是世界上第一号纽敦骗局制造者。这家伙去纽敦，作为专家出现在亚历克斯·琼斯的节目中。他甚至呼吁纽敦的父母挖出他们孩子的遗体以证明他们已经死了。
Halbig ordered a background check on Lenny, then sent it out in an email to lots of people. It was almost 100 pages, listing everything from his Social Security number and phone number, to almost every address he'd ever lived at, with photos. Names of his relatives were included too.
哈尔比格对莱尼进行了背景调查，然后通过电子邮件发送给了很多人。差不多有100页，列出了从他的社会保障号和电话号码，到他住过的几乎每一个地址，还有照片。他亲戚的名字也包括在内。
The online harassment had become so intense that Lenny and Veronique and their two girls went into hiding. They moved into separate high-security gated communities. But Lenny's address kept getting exposed, and hoaxers started posting videos of where he lived.
网络骚扰变得如此强烈，以至于莱尼和维罗妮克以及他们的两个女儿躲了起来。他们搬进了高安全性的门禁社区。但莱尼的地址不断被曝光，骗局制造者开始发布他住在哪里的视频。
One apartment that I had moved into, I had only lived there, I think, for a month. And I got a call from a particular hoaxer-- who happens to be in prison now for attempted murder. And he called me up, and was acting like a smart ass, and then read me my Social Security number, and then read me my address where I had just moved into. And I said, well, you know what, I don't like this apartment that much anyway. And I moved shortly after that.
我搬进的一套公寓，我想我只住了一个月。我接到一个特定骗局制造者的电话——他现在正好因企图谋杀而在监狱里。他打电话给我，表现得像个自以为是的人，然后读出我的社会保障号，然后读出我刚搬进来的地址。我说，好吧，你知道吗，我反正也不怎么喜欢这套公寓。没多久我就搬走了。
To try and throw the hoaxers off, Lenny started putting utility bills in different names, and got multiple PO boxes all over the place. All this forced Lenny into a new battle strategy. If they were going to expose him, he'd do the same to them. He wrote newspaper op-eds, calling out Halbig and the others by name. And when these hoaxers posted his new addresses online, he did the same to them.
为了试图摆脱骗局制造者，莱尼开始用不同的名字缴纳水电费，并到处弄了多个邮政信箱。所有这些迫使莱尼采取了新的战斗策略。如果他们要曝光他，他也以牙还牙。他写了报纸专栏文章，点名批评哈尔比格和其他人。当这些骗局制造者在网上发布他的新地址时，他也对他们做了同样的事。
He also made it so that if you googled their names, the first thing anyone would see was all the Sandy Hook garbage they'd created. And Lenny being Lenny decided to write a biography about Wolfgang Halbig's life, called The Hoax of a Lifetime. He released it as an e-book. Lenny became "the one who knocks."
他还做了这样一件事：如果你谷歌他们的名字，任何人看到的第一个东西就是他们制造的所有桑迪胡克的垃圾。而莱尼毕竟是莱尼，他决定写一本关于沃尔夫冈·哈尔比格生平的传记，名为《一生骗局》。他把它作为电子书发布。莱尼成了“敲门的那个人”。
He calls this troll wrestling. It's like trolling the trolls. He gets both energized and sheepish when talking about it. He insists sometimes the only way to fight hardcore hoaxers is to turn the tables on them. And it worked on some of them. It freaked them out.
他把这称为喷子摔跤。这就像是戏弄喷子。当谈到这个时，他既充满活力又有点腼腆。他坚持有时打击顽固的骗局制造者的唯一方法就是以其人之道还治其人之身。这在一些人身上奏效了。这让他们感到害怕。
Still, Lenny was just one guy. And every day, new mountains of content about Noah were showing up online. His crusade was a lonely one. The hoaxers seemed so dangerous, most of the other Newtown parents wanted to stay as far away as possible from them.
尽管如此，莱尼只是一个人。每天，关于诺亚的新内容山一样出现在网上。他的远征是孤独的。骗局制造者看起来非常危险，大多数其他纽敦的父母希望尽可能远离他们。
In my darker moments, the conspiracy part of me would return and ask myself, am I the only one that lost a child? Why am I the only one fighting back? I mean, what the hell is going on?
在我比较黑暗的时刻，我内心阴谋论的那部分会回归并问自己，我是唯一一个失去孩子的人吗？为什么我是唯一一个反击的人？我的意思是，到底发生了什么？
I mean, people were trampling all over other peoples' children's memories. And those children no longer had a voice to defend themselves. And people were just silent about it.
我的意思是，人们在践踏其他孩子的记忆。而那些孩子不再有声音为自己辩护。而人们对此只是保持沉默。
But while Lenny was escalating his tactics, so was the other side. Around the second anniversary of Sandy Hook, a small group of conspiracy theorists made an almost three-hour movie on YouTube questioning the shooting. They described themselves as independent journalists and researchers, but their backgrounds were totally random. They included a magician, the owner of a moving company, a guy who'd been arrested for stabbing someone five times, and a stay-at-home dad.
但当莱尼在升级他的战术时，对方也是如此。桑迪胡克两周年纪念日左右，一小群阴谋论者在YouTube上制作了一部近三个小时的电影，质疑这次枪击事件。他们称自己为独立记者和研究人员，但他们的背景完全是随机的。他们包括一名魔术师、一家搬家公司的老板、一个因刺伤某人五次而被捕的人，还有一个全职爸爸。
I just had an idea that I wanted to be an underground filmmaker myself.
我只是有个想法，我想自己成为一名地下电影制作人。
This is Doug Maguire. He says he met this group online on YouTube and got brought in at the end to help polish the movie. It felt exciting. At the time, Doug was a struggling filmmaker in Los Angeles. Occasionally he did some stunt work.
这是道格·麦奎尔。他说他是在YouTube上遇到这群人的，最后被拉进去帮助润色电影。这感觉很令人兴奋。当时，道格是洛杉矶的一名挣扎的电影制作人。偶尔他会做一些特技工作。
He got into conspiracy theories the way lots of people do-- watching them on YouTube. Like Lenny, he loved the ones about Bigfoot and UFOs. But then he went to look up news about Sandy Hook. And YouTube's recommendation system started suggesting hoax videos.
他像许多人一样接触阴谋论——在YouTube上观看它们。像莱尼一样，他喜欢关于大脚怪和UFO的那些。但他去查询关于桑迪胡克的新闻。而YouTube的推荐系统开始建议骗局视频。
He didn't believe the theory that the kids were actors. He thought children died. But he felt pretty sure there was some other kind of cover-up going on, maybe one with the mafia.
他不相信孩子们是演员的理论。他认为孩子们确实死了。但他感觉很确定还有某种其他的掩盖正在发生，也许是与黑手党有关的。
And where did you get that information? Like, where did you come up with this idea of a mob? Had you read this somewhere?
那你从哪里得到这些信息？比如，你是怎么想出这个黑手党主意的？你在哪里读到过吗？
No, it was because I make movies. So I think I have an active imagination.
没有，这是因为我制作电影。所以我认为我有活跃的想象力。
Wait, hold on, I'm confused. Like, what was your thinking?
等一下，等等，我糊涂了。比如，你的想法是什么？
A family had done someone wrong. Like, let's say the movie Goodfellas. OK? Henry Hill is hiding out in a little village.
一个家庭做错了事。比如，让我们说电影《好家伙》。对吗？亨利·希尔躲在一个小村庄里。
He also mentioned Kindergarten Cop.
他还提到了《幼儿园警察》。
When they release their film, they uploaded it to a bunch of different accounts, on places like YouTube, Vimeo, and Dailymotion. Pretty soon, it was showing up everywhere.
当他们发布电影时，他们将其上传到许多不同的账户，比如YouTube、Vimeo和Dailymotion。没过多久，它就到处都是了。
To combat this, Lenny had to change tactics one final time. No more talking to hoaxers one-on-one. Now, the thing he'd focus on was content removal-- scrubbing their stuff off the internet.
为了对抗这一点，莱尼不得不最后一次改变战术。不再与骗局制造者一对一交谈。现在，他关注的重点是内容删除——把他们的东西从互联网上清除。
He decided he was going to get every single copy of the movie taken down, which wasn't going to be easy. He couldn't just write into YouTube and say, hey, this video is full of lies. That wasn't going to be enough. The internet is full of lies. He needed something else. And he realized he had it.
他决定要让这部电影的每一份拷贝都被删除，这并不容易。他不能仅仅写信给YouTube说，嘿，这个视频充满了谎言。那是不够的。互联网充满了谎言。他需要别的东西。他意识到他有它。
These conspiracy theorists had used photos and videos of him, and Noah, and Veronique. Those were his property, making this movie a copyright violation. The stolen images were now a useful weapon.
这些阴谋论者使用了他和诺亚以及维罗妮克的照片和视频。那是他的财产，这使得这部电影构成了版权侵权。被盗图像现在成了有用的武器。
Lenny tracked down every place where this video was posted. And you've probably seen this. There's a little button you can click on to report stuff. So that's what he did for hours every day. And success-- sort of. The hoaxers kept re-posting and moving the video on to other sites.
莱尼追踪到这个视频被发布的每一个地方。你可能见过这个。有一个小按钮可以点击来举报东西。所以这就是他每天花费数小时所做的。成功——算吧。骗局制造者不断重新发布并把视频移动到其他网站。
You know, the crazies are not running the asylum. It's the platforms who are allowing this to go on. So that solidifies it for me that we have to just remove all of this garbage, and that's all we need to do.
你知道，疯子们并没有统治疯人院。是允许这种情况发生的平台。所以这对我来说强化了这一点，我们必须清除所有这些垃圾，而这就是我们所需要做的。
But this, of course, pissed off a lot of hoaxers.
但这当然惹恼了很多骗局制造者。
We don't know what's going on. We just know it doesn't look right.
我们不知道发生了什么。我们只知道看起来不对劲。
Alex Jones. He was stumped. Lenny had successfully forced the Infowars site to remove pictures of Noah using copyright.
亚历克斯·琼斯。他被难住了。莱尼利用版权成功强制Infowars网站删除了诺亚的照片。
So frustrating. This is amazing. The claimant is Lenny Pozner. They think because they can hold out some little kids and say we're shutting people's websites down because they're belittling the memory of these children-- no, we're not. But even if we were, you couldn't violate our First Amendment, because that's what it's there for. And if you take our rights, you take everybody's rights.
真让人沮丧。这太神奇了。索赔人是莱尼·波兹纳。他们认为因为他们可以拿出一些小孩说我们在关闭人们的网站，因为他们贬低这些孩子的记忆——不，我们没有。但即使我们有，你也不能违反我们的第一修正案，因为这就是它存在的原因。如果你夺走了我们的权利，你就夺走了所有人的权利。
Then Jones put one of the guys who worked on the movie on the air. His name is Brian. He's from Alabama.
然后琼斯让制作电影的人之一上了节目。他的名字叫布莱恩。他来自阿拉巴马。
What do you think of us being censored? What's been happening to you?
你觉得我们被审查怎么看？你身上发生了什么？
I can tell you a lot about Lenny. This man is something that you've never seen before. He's got a group of trolls. And if you--
我可以告诉你很多关于莱尼的事。这个男人是你从未见过的那种人。他有一群喷子。如果你——
I mean, if they're trying to shut us down when we're just investigating it and looking at all sides, it must be horrible for folks out there that vehemently think this is staged. So just specifically, what have you gone through?
我的意思是，如果他们试图在我们仅仅是调查它并从各方面观察时就关闭我们，那么对于外面那些坚决认为这是策划的人来说，这一定很可怕。所以具体来说，你经历了什么？
I can't even put up a video showing that he has put up a copyright strike against me without him copyrighting striking that. These people are vile. And Lenny, if you're listening, your day is coming, my friend. It is coming.
我甚至不能发布一段视频显示他对我发布了版权投诉，而他没有对他进行版权投诉。这些人是卑鄙的。莱尼，如果你在听，你的日子到了，我的朋友。它到了。
Wow, I mean, this sounds like a war is going on. I think they made a major mistake involving us.
哇，我的意思是，这听起来像是在进行一场战争。我觉得他们惹上我们犯了一个重大错误。
Oh, I totally agree. They don't know what they've bit off. Go after them, Alex. Crush them.
哦，我完全同意。他们不知道他们惹上了什么。去对付他们，亚历克斯。粉碎他们。
In this video on YouTube, Jones showed his fans-- he had millions of them-- Lenny's email, the city he lived in, and the address he picked up his mail. He even held up some satellite shots from Google Earth. Lenny got this video taken down too, flagging it for privacy violations.
在这个YouTube视频中，琼斯向他的粉丝展示——他有数百万粉丝——莱尼的电子邮件、他居住的城市以及他取件的地址。他甚至举起了一些来自谷歌地球的卫星截图。莱尼也删除了这个视频，以隐私违规为由举报了它。
But it didn't matter. The hoaxers had taken on a mob mentality, pursuing and harassing Lenny. This is an Infowars fan named Lucy Richards, who left multiple death threats on Lenny's phone.
但这没关系。骗局制造者采用了暴民心态，追求和骚扰莱尼。这是一个叫露西·理查兹的Infowars粉丝，她在莱尼的电话上留下了多条死亡威胁。
Did you hide your imaginary son in the attic? Are you still fucking him? You fucking Jew bastard.
你把你的虚构儿子藏在阁楼里了吗？你还在强奸他吗？你这个该死的犹太杂种。
You're going to die. You're going to rot in hell. Death is coming to you real soon and there's nothing you can do about it. So you're just going to have to take it, OK? Jew bastard. Look behind you. Death is coming to you real soon.
你会死的。你会在地狱里腐烂。死亡很快就会降临到你身上，你对此什么也做不了。所以你只能承受，好吗？犹太杂种。看看你后面。死亡很快就会降临到你身上。
She said, "Look behind you. Death is coming to you real soon."
她说，“看看你后面。死亡很快就会降临到你身上。”
Lenny was already living in hiding. He'd moved multiple times by then because hoaxers kept tracking down his address. But now the chances that a hoaxer might show up at his door and kill him suddenly felt much higher. His kids were living with him half the week, and he worried about them.
莱尼已经躲藏起来生活了。那时候他已经搬了好几次家，因为骗局制造者一直在追踪他的地址。但现在一个骗局制造者可能会出现在他门口杀掉他的可能性突然感觉高多了。他的孩子们一周有一半时间和他住在一起，他很担心他们。
At the same time, he didn't consider stopping. He didn't think it would make them safer.
同时，他没有考虑停止。他不认为这会让他们更安全。
That's one of the misconceptions that exist, that people think that I am only targeted because of challenging the content. And that's not the case. I took the action because I was being targeted. So if my address is published all over the internet, my photo was published all over the internet, and my living children's photos are published online, that existed before I did anything. I didn't cause the targeting. It was already there. I was minimizing the targeting.
这是一个存在的误解，人们认为我只是因为挑战内容才被针对的。事实并非如此。我采取行动是因为我一直被针对。所以如果我的地址被发布在互联网上，我的照片被发布在互联网上，而我活着的孩子的照片也被发布在网上，那在我做任何事之前就存在了。我没有导致被针对。它已经在那里了。我是在最小化被针对。
He posted receipts for firearms. I'd asked if he actually bought them, and he wouldn't give me an answer.
他发布了枪支的收据。我问他是否真的买了它们，他没有给我回答。
Amidst all this, Lenny kept up his daily ritual. He'd wake up, make coffee, and then sit in front of his computer for hours, flagging content, trying to systematically erase Noah from the Sandy Hook hoax story.
在这一切之中，莱尼保持着他的日常仪式。他会醒来，煮咖啡，然后坐在电脑前几个小时，举报内容，试图系统地从桑迪胡克骗局故事中抹去诺亚。
There was a lot of stuff he couldn't invoke copyright law for, like the death threats and harassment. That was much harder to get taken down. The tech companies were wary of becoming arbiters of truth, making decisions about what its users could and couldn't say. But Lenny, in his usual methodical fashion, kept chipping away.
有很多东西他不能援引版权法，比如死亡威胁和骚扰。那很难被删除。科技公司对成为真相的仲裁者、决定用户可以和不能说什么持谨慎态度。但莱尼，以他一贯有条不紊的方式，一直在削弱它们。
On YouTube, he kept a scorecard. Once he nailed someone with three copyright strikes, YouTube would remove their accounts. He killed thousands of videos this way. The hoaxers called this "getting Poznered." He'd become a hashtag.
在YouTube上，他保留了一张记分卡。一旦他给某人贴上三个版权警示，YouTube就会删除他们的账户。他用这种方式干掉了成千上万的视频。骗局制造者称这为“波兹纳化”。他变成了一个标签。
Then he and Veronique helped get a professor in Florida named James Tracy fired. This guy had harassed them for years and kept using Noah's image to promote his conspiracy theories. He's also the one who helped popularize the conspiracy term "crisis actor" on his blog right after the shooting.
然后他和维罗妮克帮助解雇了一位名叫詹姆斯·特雷西的佛罗里达教授。这家伙骚扰了他们多年，并一直使用诺亚的形象来推广他的阴谋论。他也是枪击事件后在他的博客上帮助推广阴谋论术语“危机演员”的人。
And that woman who was leaving death threats, Lucy Richards, Lenny reported her to the police and they arrested her. She was sentenced to five months in jail.
而那个留下死亡威胁的女人，露西·理查兹，莱尼向警察举报了她，他们逮捕了她。她被判入狱五个月。
The judge rebuked her for going after Lenny, saying, quote, "This is a reality and there is no fiction. There are no alternative facts." He barred her from Infowars and other conspiracy websites as one of the conditions of her parole.
法官斥责她去追逐莱尼，说，引用，“这是一个现实，没有虚构。没有替代事实。”他禁止她访问Infowars和其他阴谋论网站，作为她假释条件之一。
One surprising thing that happened over the years is that some of the hoaxers who used to harass Lenny flipped to his side. There were dozens of them. Lenny says these were people who came to him only after they changed their own minds, not people he tried to convert. He says that never works. It's a waste of time.
多年来发生的一件令人惊讶的事情是，一些曾经骚扰莱尼的骗局制造者转到了他这一边。有好几十个。莱尼说这些人只有在他们自己改变主意后才来找他，而不是他试图转化的人。他说那永远不会奏效。那是浪费时间。
Some of them became disenchanted when they saw Sandy Hook hoaxers who were more interested in photoshopping evidence and getting online followers than tracking down the truth. One of them was Doug, who worked on that hoaxer movie about Sandy Hook. In 2016, he found a phone number for Lenny and left a voicemail.
当他们看到桑迪胡克的骗局制造者对Photoshop证据和获取在线粉丝的兴趣多过追踪真相时，其中一些人变得幻灭了。其中一个是道格，他参与制作了那部关于桑迪胡克的骗局电影。2016年，他找到了莱尼的一个电话号码并留下了语音留言。
"Hey, Lenny Pozner, this is dickhead Doug Maguire. If you ever need me, if you ever want to get a hold of me and learn about what all these people are up to, here's my number."
“嘿，莱尼·波兹纳，我是混蛋道格·麦奎尔。如果你需要我，如果你想和我联系并了解这些人都在做什么，这是我的号码。”
Did you apologize in that message?
你在那条信息中道歉了吗？
I don't believe I did.
我不相信我有。
Not surprisingly, Lenny didn't return his call. Doug was reaching out to Lenny because the hoaxers had turned on him too. He says he started feuding with some of them after he made a video exposing a Christian YouTuber who was making money off false, outrageous claims. All of his social media accounts then got hacked. Lenny was the only person he could think of who knew how to fight back. He wanted advice.
不出所料，莱尼没有回他的电话。道格联系莱尼是因为骗局制造者也反过来对付他了。他说他在制作了一个揭露一个靠虚假、令人发指的说法赚钱的基督教YouTube用户的视频后，开始和他们中的一些人结怨。他所有的社交媒体账户都被黑了。莱尼是他能想到的唯一知道如何反击的人。他想要建议。
So he tried him again and got through. He told Lenny that it felt like he'd been sort of brainwashed, that he'd been on a roller coaster ride, that he wanted to switch sides.
所以他再次尝试了他并接通了。他告诉莱尼，这感觉就像他被洗脑了，他坐了一趟过山车，他想换边站。
Lenny had started a nonprofit called The HONR Network, where volunteers help families from mass tragedies fight digital harassment. So Doug began helping him scrub content.
莱尼创办了一个名为HONR网络的非营利组织，志愿者在那里帮助来自大规模悲剧的家庭打击数字骚扰。所以道格开始帮助他清理内容。
When you were doing it, did you feel like you were doing penance?
当你在做这件事时，你觉得你在赎罪吗？
Yeah. Yeah. And my heart is very heavy for this.
是的。是的。我的心为此感到非常沉重。
Were you surprised at how quickly Lenny let you in?
你对莱尼如此快地接纳你感到惊讶吗？
Yeah. And I still am. The fact that he even is giving me a chance, I'm very humbled.
是的。我现在依然惊讶。他甚至给我一个机会的事实，我感到非常谦卑。
I tell him I love him. I tell him that he's, like, my mentor. Sometimes I call him "boss," and he says, "Don't call me boss." So--
我告诉他我爱他。我告诉他他就像我的导师。有时我叫他“老板”，他说，“别叫我老板。”所以——
Have you apologized to other families at Sandy Hook?
你向桑迪胡克的其他家庭道歉了吗？
No. I think just to try to, like, call up one of these families, that-- they don't-- they don't need to hear from some kind of YouTuber guy in Los Angeles. I think, like, one day-- I am very sorry, very sorry for any problems to the-- to any victims.
没有。我认为只是试图，比如，给这些家庭中的一个打电话，那——他们不需要——他们不需要听到来自洛杉矶的某个YouTube家伙的话。我想，有一天——我非常抱歉，对任何问题——对任何受害者感到非常抱歉。
Doug is now one of Lenny's most devoted volunteers. Lenny's got more than 100 people helping him out at any given time, though the burnout rate is high because the work is so intense. And hoaxers harass volunteers like Doug all the time for helping Lenny.
道格现在是莱尼最忠诚的志愿者之一。莱尼随时都有超过100人帮助他，尽管因为工作太紧张，倦怠率很高。而骗局制造者一直骚扰像道格这样的志愿者因为他们帮助莱尼。
When Lenny googles Noah's name now, he no longer gets page after page of hoaxer content. A lot of it is gone now. Instead, the first hits that come up are news articles about Lenny's fight to make the tech companies more accountable. For years, he's been criticizing them in the press for not doing more to protect families of mass tragedies from online abuse.
当莱尼现在谷歌诺亚的名字时，他不再看到一页又一页的骗局制造者内容。现在很多都消失了。相反，出现的第一个点击是关于莱尼为使科技公司更负责任而斗争的新闻文章。多年来，他一直在媒体上批评他们没有做更多的事情来保护大规模悲剧受害者家庭免受网络虐待。
Last summer, he and Veronique called out Mark Zuckerberg in an open letter in The Guardian. They wrote, quote, "You, arguably the most powerful man on the planet, have deemed that the attacks on us are immaterial, that providing assistance in removing threats is too cumbersome, and that our lives are less important than providing a safe haven for hate."
去年夏天，他和维罗妮克在《卫报》的一封公开信中点名批评了马克·扎克伯格。他们写道，引用，“你，可以说地球上最有权力的人，认为对我们的攻击无关紧要，认为提供删除威胁的协助太繁琐，而且我们的生活不如提供一个仇恨的安全避难所重要。”
Shortly after, Facebook reached out to Lenny. He started working with their content moderators and policymakers, and says their response times are now much faster.
不久后，Facebook联系了莱尼。他开始与他们的内容版主和政策制定者合作，并表示他们的响应时间现在快多了。
He also helped turn up the heat on Alex Jones. Last spring, he and Veronique, and another dad from Newtown, filed defamation lawsuits against him. Other parents followed with their own suit.
他还帮助对亚历克斯·琼斯施加了压力。去年春天，他和维罗妮克，以及另一位来自纽敦的父亲，对他提起了诽谤诉讼。其他父母也跟着提起了自己的诉讼。
A few months later, Apple started removing Jones's material from iTunes, saying they would not, quote, "tolerate hate speech." Facebook, Google, and Spotify then followed suit. YouTube killed his channel completely, but you can still find his videos on the platform. And Twitter was one of the last to take action against Jones and Infowars. The New York Times reported that getting deplatformed cut his online audience nearly in half.
几个月后，苹果开始从iTunes中删除琼斯的材料，称他们不会，引用，“容忍仇恨言论”。Facebook、谷歌和Spotify随后效仿。YouTube彻底关闭了他的频道，但你仍然可以在平台上找到他的视频。而Twitter是最后一个对琼斯和Infowars采取行动的平台之一。据《纽约时报》报道，被去平台化使他的在线观众减少了近一半。
I met up with Lenny at his place recently. He lives in a gated, high-security residence. He was filing copyright and harassment reports to places like Instagram, Pinterest, Reddit, Vimeo, and Twitter. He says Twitter is his biggest headache right now. There's content about Noah he still can't get down. And he gets personally attacked there all the time.
我最近在莱尼的住处见了他。他住在一个有门禁、高安全性的住宅里。他正在向Instagram、Pinterest、Reddit、Vimeo和Twitter等平台提交版权和骚扰报告。他说Twitter是他现在最大的头痛问题。关于诺亚的内容他仍然无法删除。而且他在那里一直受到人身攻击。
Do you feel like you've like jumped in this rabbit hole that is never going to end?
你觉得你是不是跳进了这个永远不会结束的兔子洞？
I don't think I jumped in. I think I just got pulled in.
我不认为我跳进去了。我觉得我只是被拉进去了。
You're just constantly subjecting yourself to just so much hateful material.
你一直在让自己承受如此多的仇恨素材。
Just like throwing trash out. Once it's gone, it feels really good. It really does.
就像扔垃圾一样。一旦它消失了，感觉真的很好。真的很好。
This is what victory looks like-- taking the trash out every day. He recently spotted one of the hoaxers who's been after him. Turns out, the person lives nearby. Lenny's about to have to move again. This will be the eighth time.
这就是胜利的样子——每天把垃圾倒掉。他最近发现了其中一个一直盯着他的骗局制造者。事实证明，那个人住在附近。莱尼快要不得不再次搬家了。这将是第八次。
Miki Meek. Since we first broadcast this story in 2019, Lenny, Veronique, and other parents from Sandy Hook have scored some big victories. They won defamation lawsuits against Alex Jones.
米奇·米克。自我们2019年第一次播出这个故事以来，莱尼、维罗妮克和其他来自桑迪胡克的父母取得了巨大胜利。他们赢得了针对亚历克斯·琼斯的诽谤诉讼。
Lenny and these families also received a $73 million settlement from Remington. It is notoriously difficult to sue gun manufacturers for the way their guns are used, but the families focused on how Remington marketed their guns to very young people. This is the largest payout a gun manufacturer has ever given out for a mass shooting.
莱尼和这些家庭还收到了雷明顿7300万美元的和解金。起诉枪支制造商因其枪支被使用的方式而臭名昭著地困难，但这些家庭专注于雷明顿如何向非常年轻的人销售他们的枪支。这是枪支制造商有史以来为大规模枪击事件支付的最大赔偿。
[MUSIC - "THE WATER" BY JOHNNY FLYNN FEAT. LAURA MARLING]
[音乐 - 约翰尼·弗林 feat. 劳拉·马琳 的“水”]
Well, today's program was put together by Emanuele Berry, David Kestenbaum, Miki Meek, and myself, with production help from Michele Navarro, Stowe Nelson, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu.
好了，今天的节目是由伊曼纽尔·贝里、大卫·克斯滕鲍姆、米奇·米克和我本人制作的，感谢米歇尔·纳瓦罗、斯托·尼尔森、马特·蒂尔尼和黛安·吴的制作帮助。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's videos, and lists of favorite shows, tons of other stuff there. Again, thisamericanlife.org.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以绝对免费地流媒体播放我们超过750集节目的档案。此外，还有视频，最喜欢节目的列表，网站上还有大量其他东西。再次说明，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he told me he went to see this documentary about navy pilots this week. He was completely outraged. He said it had a bombastic tone, it was overdramatic. He told me, whoever put together this documentary, Top Gun: Maverick, does not understand the basic principles of journalism.
《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台PRX传送给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他告诉我他这周去看了那个关于海军飞行员的纪录片。他完全被激怒了。他说它的语气夸大，过于戏剧化。他告诉我，无论谁制作了这个纪录片，《壮志凌云：独行侠》，都不理解新闻的基本原则。
They clearly used actors.
他们显然使用了演员。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多美国生活的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "THE WATER" BY JOHNNY FLYNN FEAT. LAURA MARLING]
[音乐 - 约翰尼·弗林 feat. 劳拉·马琳 的“水”]